got a csi bro we are playing black
definitely a strong opponent and good
luck to you
at f6
okay we're just gonna play
play nice and solid d5
it's already something weird
go b6
he brings the bishop out early so
he's doing something very weird
yeah i i figured he might go for this
and i was planning on doing something
very similar
so yeah let's let's go for it
i guess we'll pre-move that
we go for c5
plays c3
it's no problem
probably get this knight to d5 it's what
we want to do
stop the knight from coming to you g5
it's a little bit tricky
let's play queen d7 try to discourage f5
we've seen kindergarteners play better
than csi
go with knight d5 luckily bishop b5 is
not really a concern
we're gonna go with f5 here
something i wanted to do queen d7 we've
got queen f7 on the rocks
so
should be good there although i realize
now
that bishop b5 is a move but we can just
sidestep
it's okay
and
if he trades queens then we should be
good to go
should be okay his knight's kind of dead
hit the queen again now question is if
he takes do you take with the knight or
the king or the pawn probably not the
pawn
i think i just played king f7 here and
this pawn structure i think makes it
very difficult for him to get any
activity over here
takes we take the bishop
okay play queen g6 we have a pretty big
threat here
so we used to parry it somehow i think
mainly just opening up this square for
the knight
you know in case c4 ever happens we want
to be able to move our knight here i
don't think he has a good way of
attacking our queen so i think we're
okay there what's the plan
what's the plan man
is this a good plan
let's just develop i think it's
important to connect our rooks so
there's okay
this should be okay that's why we moved
our queen right
now
his queen a very expected response your
queen's attacked you move your queen
that's what you do a little bit stuck
here not sure exactly what i want to do
is he gonna play b4
maybe
that was the other move i thought he
might play
play h5 knight's kind of stuck here so
we should be okay
i don't know if we have to actually move
him it's a very risky play
but i'm going for it i think it works
what do you guys think
he goes for it okay
definitely turning into
quite the spicy meatball here
i thought he had two
so if i take how is he getting out
do i just win the game
i guess he takes with a queen and then
he has to take with the right piece here
this tactic almost works too bad
gives the king an escape square
oh shoot
i didn't see that
okay
panic time
oh no
the risky biscuit
and we're way down on time
did we just win
did we just win the game
baby
oh yeah get him out of here
that's what i like to call a checkmate
the gambit paid off the night sack on g4
oh yeah
all right wahoo csi
taking them down
fifth place with five points
two games left
but it's not going to affect our
standings
we got fifth place
with five points we did have a big
apparently here we were
mega winning
after bishop e1 we can omega win the
game with queen h5